[Music]
yeah everybody's everybody's terrified
there we go 21 25.
all right thank you beyond repute for
the five let's go with an e4
okay we have a french
and
let's think
all right so um i propose that we play
the same line
uh that i played a couple of games ago
which is originally named after
nimesovic but peter brought it to my
attention so i call it the geonato's
french
and it starts off as an advance which is
e5
does anybody remember
what characterizes okay never mind b6
that is
a comparatively rare sideline obviously
almost everybody plays c5 in that
position
and in that position knight f3 was the
move i intended to play now here
um there is no reason to
dilly dally around we can just develop
our pieces the idea of v6 i'm familiar
with this line
uh the idea is to go bishop a6 and trade
off the bad french bishop and we have a
very clever way to play this i think
uh and that is to start with the move c3
who can tell me
why this is clever can black go bishop
a6 there
can black bish queen d7 is actually
correct but why is bishop a6 bad because
a bishop takes a6 knight takes a6 and
queen a4 picks off the knight so queen
d7 is actually correct
and this covers this diagonal in
preparation for bishop basics okay so
what i propose to do is first to develop
the bishop to d3
and
here i think most people would be
inclined to go knight f3
but i quite like the idea of putting the
knight on e2 what is the advantage of
that the advantage of that is that it
leaves the f-pawn unobstructed which
means that once we castle we have this
very typical plan
of advancing the f pawn forward as
quickly as possible to break down the
king side so
in these types of french positions i i
like putting the knight on e2 yeah he
managed to trade the light squared
bishops but that's cost him a couple of
tempe
okay first we want to develop obviously
we don't want to do anything rash
and h5 okay so he is probably preparing
knight f5
interesting interesting way to play
um
playing f4 here wouldn't be very
sensible at this point because he would
just park the night on f5 and then we
wouldn't be able to make progress
so i propose we simply develop our
pieces i don't think we should
do anything extraordinary here what does
that mean develop our pieces how
no we don't want to play h4
uh we want to let him play h4 and then
play h3 to freeze the pawn that way
yeah i think bishop g5 makes sense
sticking the bishop onto a weak square
and then getting this knight out to d2
and potentially later to f3 let's go
let's uh speed up a little bit here
knight d2
i think i think he's managed to equalize
here but
you know the better player will win c5
all right
so
very chaotic and very complex french
position
um i think
we have many we have several ways to
play this what annoys me here about
black's position is this knight i think
this knight
uh is a very troublesome piece because
it's exerting pressure on d4 and it's
clogging up the king's side
so based on what i told you guys
just a couple of moments ago i think
knight g3 makes the most sense trying to
trade off the knight
yeah very good
if he takes on g3 i think we have a very
interesting way to recapture because
the rules would tell us to capture
toward the center but if you know where
we are attacking
then
i think the correct move should be
obvious uh uh g6
wow really weakening the dark squares
bishop f6 is asking to be played but
maybe we should hold off on that move
maybe we should hold off on that move
hmm
let me think for a second
we have some very interesting stuff that
we could do here
we could take on f5
we could take an f5 at our leisure but
there's no hurry to do that
there's no there's no need to do that
immediately i think we can improve our
position first
you know what
let's stick the bishop on f6 first and
then we'll think
okay now what i propose is that we bring
this knight into the game with knight f3
and i potentially see an interesting
path via g5 to h7 and later to f6 that
would be the goal that would be the
american dream so to speak
bishop b7 now do we need to respond to
this do we need to move the bishop away
or do we let him take it
yeah we're going to centralize the rooks
but first i want people to answer that
question no we don't because if he takes
we take with the pawn and we have this
beautiful e5 square for our knight
so
what i propose we do
is actually a move that you guys will
roll your eyes at but i think is
probably good let's go a3
those of you who play the advanced
french will understand the idea of this
move i want to get this pawn out of my
hair
how do we do that
what am i preparing i want to get this
pawn out of my hair
b4
get out of here pawn on c5 obviously we
want him to take on d4 because then the
c file will open and given how weak his
king is the more files get open the
better if he goes c4 it's kind of a
win-win for us then the pawn on d4 will
no longer be under pressure our hands
are untied and we can start playing on
the king's side
if you play the advanced french you
should be familiar with this idea a3 b4
trying to get this pawn to decide what
it's going to do
so
we're building up the tension
something is going to happen right now i
feel like a lot is going on night
knights are in contact bishops are in
contact
pawns are in contact and he decides to
take on d4
which i kind of like to see because now
we're going to put a rook on c1
and we potentially have the plan of
doubling he can't really castle long
that's suicidal
and he can't castle short anymore
because he's already moved his rook yeah
[Music]
hopefully this is making sense so far
our next move is very likely to be rick
ac1 okay
what is the idea of this move
what is the idea of this move
and at this point he wants to play
knight g4 in order to dislodge their
bishop so the prophylactic approach here
would be to go h3 and
circumscribe this knight completely
we're trying to play prophylactically
here and patiently once we limit the
knight then we're going to go roxy on
this move is not going anywhere
rook c1
and we have a very clear plan of
doubling on the c file nothing
extraordinary there queen a6 is also
something to consider in certain
positions
but okay knight b8 whoa
no this has to be winning for us at this
point
okay i have an interesting proposal
what is the high level goal here high
level goal is to take control of the of
the c file in order to do that we want
to take the rook
and what move
allows us to prepare rook c1 with tempo
so how do we prepare xi1 with tempo
yeah queen e3 or queen d2
i don't know if it matters which of
these moves we make queen d2 may be
marginally more precise because
if he goes knight f5 that does not occur
with tempo and we can play rook c1
anyway although we would probably end up
taking the knight anyway
so it doesn't really matter rook c1 we
have the c file now
we've won the queen side battle let's
see if we can win the kingside battle
now obviously we need to get this knight
out of the picture
get out of here
now what does it mean to win the king
side battle what should our next move be
in fact both after gf and after actually
after
ef i think we have a much stronger move
but in case he plays gf think about how
we are going to
seize control of the king side not
knight g5 although that's a decent move
i think there is a far more direct
approach
i think there's a far more direct
approach
no need to take on e7 there's no reason
for us to trade do not trade in these
kinds of positions unless there's a
compelling reason to do so
let's get in there with the queen queen
h6
i feel like this is crushing
do you see how
we've gotten control of the key artery
in the position the c file and once
we've done that we've ensured that black
is essentially tied down the queen
cannot move because we will infiltrate
and this is a classic example of playing
on both sides of the board
we played on the queen side
we did sufficient damage and now we are
transitioning to the king side where
black is at his most vulnerable
we have many ideas in this position
first of all simply taking on h5
okay what should we take with
what should we take with
yeah let's get this beautiful juicy
square on e5
and we have some very pretty ideas
hanging in the air
some very special ideas here
okay
yeah of course you would queen d8
how do we continue accumulating the
pressure i know many of you are seeing
queen g7 i think his move was aimed
against that move because
if we go queen g7 he takes it and then
goes king up to e7 stopping the pun
so we have to be very disciplined here
in these positions
we're not playing for the brilliancy
prize we're playing
we play to win the game let me think
this is not as easy as it appears
because he wants knight d7 here
i actually i actually want to take some
time here
all right
let's go knight e5
this is not easy because he goes knight
t7 this is a lot harder than it looks
once he goes knight d7 that pawn on f6
is liable to fall and we have to be very
disciplined
all right so here i think i see a key
move
yeah so it's a simple move just taking
on h5 but actually this was hard to see
i think taking on h5 is the simplest
because
he cannot take with the queen on f6 due
to rook c8 he cannot take with the
knight and f6 due to checkmate if he
takes on e5
then we cement the pawn on f6 and the
rest should be quite easy there
maybe it's not the best but um
i think this is good enough to win
you can pre-move dtx5 rook f8
all right
all right
there's got to be a win here but i'm
kind of struggling here
i see it
i think i see it
does anybody
see the winning move
no not knight c6 guys you're sloppy
knight c6 queen takes f6
the move is rook c6 i'm pretty sure
why because of this pin we're
threatening rook takes e6 with a
devastating completely devastating
attack
this is essentially a checkmate threat
in fact this move follows even against
knight takes knight we inter mezzo rook
takes c6 and then we take the knight and
black's position is destroyed
and if he plays queen takes f6 that's
actually what took me a while is
figuring out what to do after queen
takes f6
and the wind there is very prosaic but
it's easy in retrospect but it's not so
easy when you're actually calculating
who sees it chess brainiac what's up
rook check king e7 and then what
all of you guys are giving the easy move
but what's the follow-up after king e7
it's simple
okay check
you're falling for the tempting move
you're giving a check on c6 why are you
giving this check do you see a follow-up
to king d6 or are you playing this just
because it's a check
see this is where you have to refrain
from the tempting moves
and start by looking at the captures
rook c7 is also not gg because of rook
d8
the move is to simply take the knight
see in fact i think these are the
hardest moves to find it's the simple
captures
that fall out of your field of vision
because your brain is in tactics mode
you're looking at sacrifices
and these easy moves
and when i say easy i don't literally
mean easy i mean
moves that
moves that look deceptively simple well
they're the ones that are hard to find
okay so
rook takes c8 and now we take the queen
of weapon queen this is actually a very
nice game
what's the fastest method of winning
here
identify the past spawn push it
h4 h5 etc we don't even need to think
just h5 maybe we should have given a
check on g5 first but it doesn't matter
we don't care about this bond our pawn
is much faster check and h6 on the next
move don't pre-move anything here
if you prime of h6 you might get an f6
this was a very nice game yeah
just h6 remember we have some luft so
resigns
that's a great game
um
so
let's go over quickly and then we have
box box
so b6 is a viable sideline this is one
of the main sidelines in the french
after c5 i was going to play the
gionado's french with knight f3
c takes d4 and bishop d3
and i have a speedrun game here a couple
of games ago you guys can review this
it'll eventually be up on youtube
so b6 i don't know whether i played the
theoretical move but i feel like c3 is
quite clever
bishop a6 loses a piece to takes takes
queen a4
and so queen d7 is a very common move
bishop d3
bishop a6 and 92.
idea being we are eventually preparing
f4 and this knight is often going to go
over to g3
okay takes takes
knight e7 castles and h5
so the move h5 creates a weak square on
g5 which we occupy with our bishop
uh a lot of you guys have the instinct
of going h4 but
that's not a necessary move
let me let us imagine for a second that
black drives the pawn of h4
the fact is this pawn is more of a
weakness than a strength because if we
ultimately get our knight to f3 we can
begin a direct assault on this pawn
we're not gonna get checkmated here so
it's often better to wait for your
opponent to come to h4 and then fix the
pawn like this
rather than create weaknesses of your
own with h4
okay
so we go bishop g5 occupying
weak square knight of 592
and c5
so here it's a simple matter of
identifying really the only piece that's
developed and trying to trade it off
this is a good i think piece of advice
in general when your opponent lags
behind the development
trading off his only developed piece
often serves to essentially cause the
position to collapse which is why we go
knight g3
so after knight takes g3 which he didn't
play
who can explain to me what we would have
captured with and why
this actually leads me to a small detour
and a very important point
lord clickbait thank you for the prime
yeah so you guys are all answering
correctly
um you want to capture away from the
center
you want to capture away from the center
and um
i'm trying to find a famous game that
magnus carlsen played
where he actually did something very
very similar and it was pretty shocking
when he did this i think this was either
against the rhonian
or this was against mamidyarov it's one
of the two
yeah it was against the iranian
so
this is the concept of capturing away
from the center in order to open a file
remember that keep this in the back of
your mind do not automatically capture
toward the center here fdxg3 is a
no-brainer followed by doubling on the
f-file and an immediate assault on the
f7 pawn
um
in uh magnus's carlson game
i mean i don't know why i remember that
game specifically there are many many
examples of this
but i remember when this game was played
it was like big big deal
it was like
a super super big thing
and so i guess that's why i
remembered it yeah so this was carlson
aronian 2014 i was watching this game
live
and in this very topical rugosin line
magnus plays f takes g3
uh was an insane novelty nobody had
thought to play this move
and the reason for that is because
it weakens the e3 pawn it seems
unthinkable to create such a weakness
but magnus determined
that the open f file was so important
that it was actually worth weakening the
e3 pawn over and he won the game
aronian was 28-15 when this game was
played and he didn't necessarily win
because of this novelty the position was
very unclear
and the role that the f-file actually
played
in his win is limited but the fact
remains moves like f takes g3 always
need to be considered capturing away
from the center
in order to open files something to file
away in your positional directory
okay
so g6 by our opponent
we grab the weak square created by
that last move
rook g8 knight f3 and here black's
position starts to deteriorate i don't
think he should have played bishop b7 i
think he should have developed to c6
straight away
um
but it's hard to give good advice in
such a position
bishop b7
and here i went a3 which i actually am
really happy about
trying to go before i think black should
have gone a5 i think by allowing b4 the
pressure on black's position became
essentially unbearable
um
now what would be a good idea here is
actually to play a4
and
secure this gaping hole on b5 which we
can later occupy with the queen in such
positions you don't need to be in a
hurry white just accumulates the
advantages and black's position is under
tremendous amount of pressure
you might ask also why am i not taking
on f5 is didn't i just say that we want
to eliminate black's strongest piece
well
the reason we aren't hurrying is that
there is nothing
this is not going to backfire on us we
can take on f5 whenever we want
whereas black taking on g3 would only
favor us so there's often stuff on the
chessboard where you can do it now you
can do it later you gotta always ask
yourself am i in a hurry is there a
serious risk that my opponent is going
to retract the offer he tried doing this
in the game but knight h6 was not a
serious move that knight wasn't going
anywhere and by keeping the tension
you're able to accumulate more pressure
and oftentimes you're able to keep your
options open which is what we did here
we took on f5 when the moment was right
before
and here i think definitely black should
have kept the center closed although we
would have redirected the queen to the
king side
after cdcd the position plays itself h3
stopping knight g4
why was knight for a dangerous idea
because
we do not want this bishop kicked out of
f6 we want it sitting there like a
splinter like a bone in black's throat
h3 is classic prophylaxis
now rook c1
and black got impatient knight b8 i
don't think that this really changed the
course of the game
the same thing would have happened if we
had doubled on the c file and created
you know unstoppable pressure against
the rock
boom boom boom
now simple logic we want to go rook c1
we can't go roxy one because it's
undefended so we use the undefended
knight on h6 in order to kill two birds
with one stone we force it back to f5
and we prepare c1
boom
and now that we have grabbed control of
the c file
we transition to the other side of the
board now a very instructive opportunity
would have occurred after e takes f5
of course we can play queen h6 or knight
g5 and it's winning
but
i think white has a very flashy move
that wins even faster
who can tell me what it is
yeah so this is a very classic idea
right you essentially force the pawn out
of a square and then you push it and the
reason you push it is to carve out the
square where the pawn previously was
right this is a
very classic positional idea with which
all of you guys should be very familiar
i've shown many many times
um one of my favorite games on the
subject
uh which is um
not a famous game but a very instructive
one
and i've i've shown it on the stream so
don't be surprised if you have seen this
before
okay
and my lesson with box box will begin
very shortly so
okay so this is um
jonathan rosen who was the first
scottish grandmaster
author of several very well received
books on chess psychology which i highly
recommend
and he reached this position against an
im from england
in this position he does something very
instructive
i think most of us would want to play
bishop h4 because why the hell would you
give away this bishop and yet rosen
takes on f6
and now he plays e5
d takes e5 knight ge4 occupying the
square left behind by the pawn
and the tactical justification is that
he takes f4 which would be ideal for
black does not work
because of knight takes f6 and the rook
on e8 hangs again undefended pieces are
very important and now white entombs the
bishop with f5 look at the domination
imposed on black's position by this
knight
and now white has the very simple idea
of doubling on the f-file and crashing
through on the king side the knight is
completely dominating here
simple but very nice and it's the same
general concept clearing out a square so
that your knight can occupy it
after f takes c6 95 black's position
totally collapses for instance queen d8
this should be 7 27 rook comes in with
checkmate
if queen b7 we take on e7 and
this is completely
utterly lost for black
okay um just wanted to show this as an
example of carving out a square here we
infiltrate to h6 and the game is over
takes takes
queen d8
um and
it's entirely possible i didn't play
the ideal moves no this is the top
engine move queen takes h5 very
materialistic but
very effective
if queen takes f6
the rook comes into c8
um
so rook f8 and now rook c6 is actually
very important
what's wrong with queen h7 well queen h7
doesn't do that much because of rook f8
and the rook simultaneously evades
capture and defends f7
so i think this is a hot spot for
blunders for a lot of people is these
positions where it seems like anything
wins
and i think the first step toward
avoiding blundering these positions is
to change your mentality you should
never start by assuming that a bunch of
moves win
your assumption should always in my
opinion be that there's only one winning
continuation even if there isn't but
that really helps you
create a strict basis on which you
evaluate ideas because what happens is
that you
you get lazy right you think oh this
one's this one's that one's let me just
place a move and all of a sudden the
advantage evaporates thank you marshall
for the five gifted and [ __ ] for the
sub
queen takes h5
this is a great example of that
so a lot of you were suggesting knight
c6
one move threat itis the only reason
you're tempted by this move is because
it threatens the queen but it's actually
a very bad move it clogs the c file
after queen takes f6 black is right back
into the game
how did i find rook c6 well i noticed
that the biggest advantage of white's
position is this pin so this pawn on e6
is actually a huge weakness
and using the c file we're able to
create an unstoppable threat here
if knight takes e5 then rook takes c6
king d7 and the most accurate is to give
another check on e7
and to play d takes e5 with queen takes
f5 to follow white's white discretion
um
after queen takes f6 comes the second
moment when i think a lot of you
fell
fell prey to this idea
very tempting but easy to establish that
knight c6 is wrong due to king d6 and
the king escapes kings are a very
slippery piece
unfortunately this rook on f8 is on is
defended by the knight maybe some of you
missed that so these are the moments
where you have to be the most careful
even the move rook c7
is not quite as convincing due to rook
d8
and again knight c6 check there's king
d6 and the position is not so clear now
white can play rook takes a seven and
yes white is completely winning here but
i would argue that the way that i played
is more forcing and more immediately
winning
and how do you find moves like knight
takes d7 how do you ensure that there
are no blind spots
well checks captures threats
and if you want to apply that advice
properly
remember that
no capture should be excluded from that
you shouldn't only look at fancy
captures you should look at regular
captures as well they can be the most
effective moves
and remember that just because you solve
a bunch of tactics doesn't mean that in
every position the solution will be
something fancy sometimes the simplest
possible
approach is the most effective
can you play rook takes b8 first no
because if you take here first i will
take with the knight
i will not take with the king and allow
you to fork me
right
so this idea of the knight recapturing
is quite annoying we have to play knight
takes d7 and it's very important that
the queen is under attack here and it's
also very important and i want to make
one final point here before we go with
box box
remember why i played h3 thank you for
gifting to chess brainiac why did i play
h3 initially was a prophylactic move
aimed against knight g4 but when you
play prophylactically
what happens is that your moves have
positive byproducts which you have no
idea about until you realize that they
do
so it turns out that this entire
combination would not have worked
without the move h3 because black would
have had a back rank mate
so when you play in a cautious and
sort of deep manner i often find that
you kind of get rewarded for that you
you know the 50 50 balls go your way
and you find that you kind of get lucky
uh in the right moment so
i kind of rushed this because we have a
short lesson with box box here
but um i hope that you guys enjoyed the
analysis this was a really nice game
[Music]